bonjour à tous pour débuter cette
semaine deux c'est votre tour on est au
lycée édouard belin à vesoul pour parler
d'une étude qui marche bien c'est la crs
assez du bts bonjour eric ça veut dire
quoi elle sert ace jour clément bts rsa
le bts conception réalisation des
systèmes automatiques
là on est à niveau bac et pendant deux
années
les étudiants vont apprendre leur métier
vont travailler sur des systèmes
automatisés on voit des hells de les
élèves de deuxième année qui se
travaille derrière nous exactement
l'heure est actuellement celle des
élèves de deuxième année qui sont en
train de faire des petites épées des
derniers tp une team on va dire travaux
avant de passer à la mise en en réel sur
les les projets industriels qui vont
faire en cours donnés alors la
particularité c'est qu'au lycée édouard
belin en deuxième année de bts on confie
des projets vous avez des entreprises
partenaires et l'idée c'est quoi c'est
de leur donner une mission à réaliser
quoi leur donner une mission à reds est
réelle il doit faire une machine réelle
en cours d'année et celle validée
ensuite devant un jury on est au niveau
du bétey et ça compte bien entendu pour
le diplôme ça compte vraiment pour le
diplôme c'est même le plus important
alors on va se rendre vers la promotion
de l'année dernière bonjour monsieur je
me retrouve avec mme attias mattia
l'année dernière au lycée édouard belin
ou vous a demandé de travailler sur quoi
alors on nous a demandé de travailler
sur une cintreuse semi automatisé donc
le but c'était de pouvoir cintrée une
barre de cuivre gris d'un angle de 90 à
180 degrés je vais regarder je vais vous
montrer ce que c'est c'est cette barre
delà c'est donc du cuivre recuit et donc
c'était pour une entreprise
bourguignonne avec laquelle on va
discuter dans quelques minutes
mais je vais laisser peut-être johan
l'insérer dans la machine vous deviez
faire quoi alors vous devez concevoir
toute la machine on a dû concevoir toute
la machine donc ils ont donné un cahier
des charges et notre but c'était de
répondre au cahier des charges et donc
voilà donc là on installe le cuivre dans
la machine et donc je te laisse johan
enclenché du coup il vous a fallu
beaucoup de décès beaucoup de moi de
réalisation comment ça s'est passé
alors on a fait ça à peu près sept mois
et
on a eu quelques mises au point à faire
mais ça s'est bien passé finalement
parce que finalement c'est bien passé à
les regarder
on voit le produit il est lassé de bach
cette barre de cuivre jeu l'a confié
avoue damien bonjour alors vous êtes le
client sait vous êtes l'entreprise
bourguignonne vous êtes d'adieu eux
c'est ça vous êtes une entreprise
spécialisée dans le paratonnerre c'est
ça tout à fait ça à vous servir à quoi
cette tige essentiellement sur tout ce
qui est des centres de mise à la terre
dont noah station qu'on fait sur des
sites industriels ou ou des maisons
alors c'est à cette chose vous là vous
en aviez besoin pour vous appareil vous
faisait appel à une autre entreprise qui
vous l'a donnée clé en main mais du coup
forcément qu elle l avantage de le faire
avec le lycée édouard belin et ben déjà
pour le prix de revient c'était le côté
intéressant de la chose et puis de
surtout de maîtriser le process et puis
surtout que vous connaissez bien
entrepris le lycée édouard belin c'est
pas la première fois que vous leur
demandez de réaliser des machines tout à
fait on a déjà quelques machines dans
notre peur qu'il me semble trois de mes
morts l'intérêt c'est quoi si vous êtes
sûr que l'aller les employés entre
guillemets il se donne à fond là restées
sûres et puis nous ça nous dégage du
temps de notre côté
et puis si ça peut faire profiter tout
le monde tant mieux alors on va se
tourner vers quentin maintenant parce
que ce qui est intéressant quand on sait
que pour réussir à réaliser ça eh ben on
le voit a eu pas mal d'essais avant
forcément c'est un travail assez un tp
comment ça s'est passé vous c'est moi de
création très difficile parce que il
faut concevoir sous tous les angles
quand on arrive à la fin donc la machine
complète avec les problèmes corrigés
c'est très satisfaisant par le résultat
si on regarde ça c'était quoi le souci
alors sur ce travail là pourquoi ça ne
marchait pas alors une petite mise au
point donc au niveau des vérins en fait
la déformation de la barre était plus
fort qu un vérin donc on a dû augmenter
le débit pour réduire le souci ce qui
nous a donné ça et là vous avez un
produit parfait c'est doit avoir de la
satisfaction quand vous entendez damien
dire que il faut confiance une
entreprise fait confiance au lycée
édouard belin et que avant votre travail
ah oui ben surtout de se dire que moi et
mes collègues qu'on a réussi quelque
chose comme ça et que ça va finir dans
le monde
l'industriel dans une entreprise qui va
utiliser ça fait toujours plaisir
bon et du tout vrai qu'on revoie cette
machine les les garçons je vais vous
demander à vous mme attias du coup est
ce qu elles ressemblent à ce que vous
vous imaginer au début ou est-ce qu'elle
a beaucoup changé au fil des mois alors
ça a pas mal changé
bah c'était pas du tout prévu quelle est
cette forme déjà mais on assez vite
arriver à ce résultat est là ce
résultat-là sur les programmes qu'est ce
que vous pourriez dire aux parents
d'élèves aux jeunes qui veulent se
peut-être se lancer dans le bts et
notamment peut-être dans celui-là
conception réalisation de systèmes
automatisés
là on a la preuve qu'en deux ans on est
capable de réaliser ce genre de choses
en deux ans on est capable de réaliser
ça et surtout ben ça permet de voir un
peu de tout on est capable de faire de
l'automatisme de la mécanique
donc c'est pas mal ça touche à beaucoup
de domaines damien vous même vos niveaux
de l'entreprise vous avez déjà d'autres
idées de machines à faire réaliser aux
élèves de d'edouard blanc tout à fait
je pense qu'on va se rencontrer à ses
sous peu pour pour discuter d'un nouveau
projet condor 3 3 projets en tête
après bon soumettre le projet le plus
approprié j'ai demandé aux professeurs
avec eric il nous reste quelques
secondes
eric l'a d'ailleurs les étudiants qui
sont derrière nous la dans deux semaines
nous allons leur confier des nouveaux
projets c'est ça oui exactement
on a déjà trois projets de prévus dans
différentes entreprises
on espère avoir le projet est
effectivement encore avec ade
on en a on aura un autre projet donc à
mpm de saut un troisième projet c'est la
rénovation d'un d'une machine d'un décès
de de lure ouais c'est impressionnant de
voir que les entreprises et les services
publics de la région font confiance au
lycée édouard belin bon bah voilà
c'était le bts conception de réalisation
des systèmes automatisés
c'est toujours une branche qui marche de
plus en plus voilà c'est en demain on
sera de nouveau à vesoul à demain